[Music]
we're about to talk about Banksy
shredding a painting we're gonna talk
about microwaving urine in a gas station
you know that stories from Florida first
watch this video so this is after UFC
229 whoa oh that's a beaner mcwrite-off
going over the fence at the Octagon he's
going in to fight and then here comes
Connor McGregor he tries to get over no
and then the court comes anything he
throws that cheap shot and it's just
okay not even a good brawl goes all over
Thank You Jillian show the headline so
this was from UFC 229 Habib one that was
his 27th win in a row which is the
longest streak of all time that's this
ongoing feud between them Conor McGregor
is most likely a bad person who's like
family and where he's from and his
religion and it all kind of boiled over
in this you guys think that if all of us
fought together we could take them not a
chance
no way all of us were nice one of them
these people turn their bodies into
killing machines and I use mine to get
food to sit on the couch to watch TV
look at that come on he doesn't look so
tough I mean Jordan has been working out
people have noticed right that he looks
more small oh maybe Jordan cooks well as
heck
[Music]
not a chance
and the red advance belt insect one one
one thing one thing that a lot of people
are saying is that this has like tainted
the reputation of the UFC and my
reaction to that is like really I any
chance that I get to see kind of
McGregor potentially get knocked out I
want to watch that he's so annoying and
he's like the worst
he's the worst version of Tyson ever
like you know me Mike Tyson he was doing
this it was fun probably cause he's
black but it was fun to watch Jeremy
just too much but I did appreciate
everybody got out of that was the doctor
guy so I mean everybody could have their
gate like channel this is the hat that
Habib wears before every match Natasha I
put this in here for you because I know
that you love fashion and I wasn't sure
if you would care about the the fight
side of things so what as a fashion what
do you think I think you know any wig
can really help you transform and I
think this says I love perms and it's
actually it's not a wig it's a hat it's
a no you might not know this but it's a
traditional Russian hat known as a what
is the point of the hat tell me about my
culture yes babe famously when he grew
up would wrestle bears and as a part of
his training so the legend is that this
would be true of course we can't beat
this man he's wrestling bears watching
watching both of those everybody in that
arena I was like everyone would benefit
from a Montessori education just like we
needed to take time you know just like
to think about our feelings when we're
children why would a fight be though if
they were civil and like it respects
each other
it wouldn't be interesting it's like the
mail we're all just a bunch of animals
so we love to watch sex and people
fighting that's what I want to move on
to the next story
so Banksy the famous street artist had
one of his paintings auctioned at
Sotheby's and as the gavel hit an alarm
went off and then show this video
Gillian this is so great and then oh
there was a built-in shredder art
gallery I think of that woman and so
Banksy posted that to his Instagram page
I guess Banksy has an Instagram and with
the caption the urge to destroy is also
a creative urge Picasa accent do we does
this cool art or is it pretentious
oh you know that person who when
the auction went off and they paid all
that money and it's red they were like
oh and then once it was like oh
it's actually worth more they're like
you're saying it's worth more now but
it's like somebody came up and took a
tab of like
see you want some of this bacon because
you add the pieces plus the value of
masking tape point four million plus
three dollars fell completely staged
dude no one even look like they wanna
say I'm surprised
no that's Banksy well I think we cracked
that story so we got to move on to our
last one today and this of course comes
to us from Florida where a gas station
attendant was getting tired of people
microwaving their urine in the microwave
to warm it up because I guess there is a
drug lab where people you know when you
have fake urine or urine that you got
from someone else you got to heat it up
before you turn it in because otherwise
they get suspicious to be warm and you
know those lab technicians that what
they do right away as they get the cup
and then they test you he didn't even
replace the microwave when he put that
time ya know they wiped it out maybe
it's a lady gas station exploded because
they overheated it figure it out in this
lady's defense have you ever tried to
drink cold pee it's disgusting you want
a warm it up I was joke both bite a
snake clinically one time I had a
Gatorade and then I drank it and then I
kind of blacked out and then I had to
pee in the middle of night and I was in
college I couldn't find it
so I peed but then I forgot I did that
morning surprise look you see this and
then it tasted bad but I was like oh no
it only tastes bad cuz I'm hungover I
need to drink this so I took a second
thought and then I kind of looked at in
the bubbles like this is Harvard so then
the war the warm pee was that was in the
middle of night and I was camping and is
raining and I had my little rain fly and
I didn't want to like fully crawl out to
go pee so I got into the rain fly like
this and then I let her rip it's just me
- my son Drew thank you and he left a
comment on our extra damn sketch show
feature with jr. hey what's up guys it's
me Royal Virginia daily show just one of
the pop in real quick let you know that
you're all deeply flawed except for
George Pizza here he's my best friend
thanks for a with jr. see you lunch I'm
dying and he says we would Julia is a
national treasure and yes yeah that's
right thanks for leaving the comment as
you might remember we were out in LA
shooting some stuff with the wonderful
Comedy Central Presents stand-up talent
and here's one of those clips right now
[Music]
welcome to what do they think it's funny
today our comedians are rhino Flanagan
Chris Garcia welcome we're gonna show
you a bunch of images find out what you
think is funny our competing teams today
are Jordan Hannah what's your team name
the yellow team the yellow team because
if your skin and her hair wonderful how
about Chris and Ryan the black and white
cookie face all right so first before we
begin playing we just want to get a
taste of what you think is funny so go
ahead and grab your funny not funny
paddle okay I'm going to show you an
image and then you just hold up whether
you think it's funny or not funny okay
ready
the first one what do you think funny
not funny great okay Chris waving spikes
he's got a maggot tattoo reminded me in
the 1930s I got a Hitler tattoo before
Hitler became popular Ryan you say not
funny
I say not funny I'm a big Red Sox fan
this is very serious Eduardo Rodriguez
next one here we go
funny not funny I'm gonna say it's not
funny now teams if you had to say what
do you think the comedic takes of Ryan
and Chris are what are you kind of
what's the vibe you're getting Ron's
pretty straightforward Chris you tend to
agree with Ryan so maybe I'll just watch
out for that Chris is leaning to tell a
story whereas Ryan was looking at what's
right in front of him and saying I don't
think that's funny I don't want to be
that nothing's funny yeah you're gonna
trust your gut okay okay which one is
funnier red or green yellow team what do
you think what do you think RIS is gonna
pick well I think he's gonna pick green
because you seem like a nice guy you're
married you respect women so I don't
think she's trying that funny you know
that girl's trying
yeah if you thought that was funny yeah
Wow it's gonna be really to add a future
threat yeah no pressure but you hate
women
amazing okay turn it around alright team
you got a point tell you what Ryan
didn't think that was funny why did you
pick great I just thought it was funny
that he was has his hand right here it's
like such a weird place you usually have
it here I like here but just like gently
right here
it's so stupid they made me laugh all
right Ryan you ready okay you're up next
you decide to hold up a paddle right
okay what do you guys think Ryan's gonna
choose I think he's gonna choose green
because I feel like there's like a
whimsical side to him and I feel like
people dressing up is what we're what
we're gonna I feel like him and his
friend have a picture of doing that
definitely play the doing whimsy for
sure green all right thank you guys so
much for watching really the true
winners are comedians you guys get to go
home with a shared copy of mind of
Mencia season and make sure to check out
Ryan and Kris this Friday for their
special at 11:00 and 11:30
Ryan O'Flanagan Chris Garcia thank you
so much for coming
you guys know that I'm kind of like an
MMA head I'm a MMA fighter yeah I signed
up for
last time I sign up for a two week trial
and I got too hurt to continue after
like four days which I paid someone and
when I when I was fighting her a woman
they paired me up it's not like I chose
much in the face and then he lost no
lose I was lifting her up and then she
was like don't drop me don't drop me I
was like I don't know what I what the
rules are
I'm not allowed to drop you or not like
it seems like I could drop him no I
didn't hurt a woman
oh yeah she she paid someone to beat
someone to fight a woman after
[Laughter]
[Music]